you know it's been said by a lot of
producers it's very difficult to figure
out the right song for you because your
voice is so big so powerful
that almost when you make a pop record
or a record that's for the masses they
got to figure out to like tone you down
or something in a way right it's always
no matter what I sing I don't care what
I'm singing It's considered spiritual
inspirational or something like that and
it's like well you know I'm glad you
feel that but
um that's not the nature right you want
to have a hit song yeah you know you
don't want to be known as a
inspirational
so it's tough it's tough to sort of
figure it out I always say it's like a
blessing and a curse yeah because some
people's voices are so big that they do
they sound almost like church singers or
something like that and you're like hey
wait a second I'm a little I want to be
a little more mainstream than a church I
want to get out of the church one of the
people who did manage to do that was
Whitney Houston she managed to she did
Tone it in you know create a way of
being like somebody else yes she did
yeah and talk about that after her death
where did you sing the uh you know
Grammys at the Grammys you saying I will
always love you it was oh that was
I didn't think I was gonna be able to
get through it yeah when they asked me
singing I was like I'll you know have
Whitney not pass me the torch herself I
would not have done it because I have
that much respect for her but when she
was here and I did a tribute for her at
the BET Awards she came backstage and
she did a famous balance she was like I
turned my torch to you
so that's why I was like okay I'll do it
but I was like I just don't know if I'm
gonna be able to get through it and the
another creepy part for me in that is I
used to sing this song in my mother's
house in the hallway in harmony with
with me wow it was on the record
[Music]
why'd you think you couldn't get through
it because uh you knew it was too
emotional Whitney Whitney you know like
she's always been my idol in a weird no
one knows that Dolly Parton wrote this
song I know that yeah I'm talking about
the public doesn't it yeah I know but
Whitney made it so much of her own yeah
yeah she did it yeah
were you afraid that you wouldn't be
able to deliver the goods that night
when you're saying this
I hadn't sang this song since high
school and
and barely had the news that she passed
we were getting ready for the pre-grammy
right and my assistant flew in the room
and was like you heard and I'm like her
what and he's like Whitney Houston
passed and it wasn't even
minutes and the phone rang and it was
like they want you to sing so it's like
it's just a lot
and it it hit close to home in so many
different ways so and again it's like
I really got emotional on the stage it's
like I'm singing this song
on this stage in honor of Whitney
Houston because she's not here to sing
it for herself and right now I could cry
just thinking about that like Yeah and I
don't know I know I feel like I don't
like it's any closure with her being
gone like it's just like what happened
how why